we're living in a very unusual time line
my friends a stock car racing league
NASCAR has banned the Confederate flag
at all events and properties period
while the President of the United States
on the same day a rich guy raised in New
York City is loudly defending
confederate named military bases in the
united states says he will not change
the names of those bases and is being
called the Confederacy second president
by a Republican group so especially for
our viewers outside the US but also for
people in the United States just as a
sort of refresher the Confederate flag
was the flag of the Confederacy in the
American Civil War you had the Union
versus the Confederacy some called that
North versus South the Confederacy
fighting for slavery sometimes they say
they were fighting for states rights to
which I always like to say states rights
to continue having legal slavery whereas
the Union was fighting to abolish
slavery of course the Union won and
slavery was abolished and the effects of
slavery of course took much longer than
just that war to actually deal with but
there are parts of this country where
Confederate flags are sometimes also
called the rebel flag they are revered
or fetishized in some way even in the
sort of hill towns in western
Massachusetts where I went near where I
went to high school you would have
places just ten or fifteen miles out of
Northampton Massachusetts which was a
super liberal little city that you know
the guys thought it was cool to drive in
to the vocational school with a pickup
truck that bore a confederate flag on
the back and there are those who I
believe rightly see it as a symbol of
hatred and oppression and there are
others who say it is a symbol of history
and heritage but in any case it is
widely now in popular culture being
eliminated and quite frankly I believe
that it should be I mean would we apply
you know look at the losers in other
conflicts losers that are forged
losers because they wanted horrible
things like could we say that displaying
Nazi flags just because they lost is
just its history like there was a German
military and it's just wrecking like
okay guys it's an extreme example but I
find it to be in very very poor taste
now this gets us to NASCAR NASCAR in the
United States is not known for being
made up of the most progressive people
now I'm not saying NASCAR fans are all
racists but it's certainly a sport that
leans more conservative in terms of its
fan base and it's one of the few places
where Donald Trump can actually get
himself a crowd that cheers instead of a
crowd that boos and it is a place where
unfortunately Confederate flags are
certainly more common than in other
sports you don't tend to see Confederate
flags at NBA games you don't tend to see
Confederate flags at major league soccer
matches and as far as I know they
wouldn't even be allowed in to be
perfectly frank but you do see them at
NASCAR races until now NASCAR has now
banned the display of the Confederate
flag at all events and properties and
notably NASCAR also removed its rule
that says racing team members have to
stand for the national anthem and we've
seen a number of sports leagues now say
you know if you don't want to stand you
actually don't have to stand so every
indication here is NASCAR sees what's
happening nationally since the killing
of George Floyd Bubba Wallace one of
their racers has been very supportive a
drivers I think they're called has-been
shows what I know has been very
supportive of the protests and they are
making a decision that there is going to
be no more Confederate stuff at their
races now is it because everybody
involved
morally believes that there shouldn't be
Confederate flags I don't know certainly
they've made the business decision that
there will be no more confederate flags
they're not everybody's happy NASCAR
Truck Series driver ray Sorelli
Ciccarelli wrote on his Facebook page
he's gonna quit after this season
because Confederate flags have been
banned have fun buddy don't let the door
hit you on the way out and then here's
the real amazing contrast look at the
last 24 hours in NASCAR
okay and compare that to the last 24
hours of Trump Trump putting out a
statement and tweeting that he will not
change the names of Confederacy themed
military bases saying quote it has been
suggested that we should rename as many
as 10 of our legendary military bases
such as Fort Bragg in North Carolina
Fort Hood in Texas Fort Benning in
Georgia these monumental and very
powerful bases have become part of a
great American heritage and a history of
winning victory and freedom the United
States of America trained and deployed
these our heroes on these hallowed
grounds and won two world wars therefore
my administration will not even consider
the renaming of these magnificent and
fabled military installations our
history as the greatest nation in the
world will not be tampered with respect
our military now what's funny about
respect our military is that remember
the Union won the Civil War meaning that
the military should be respected the
military that should be respected is the
military that fought against the
Confederacy because we won the Union won
so when you name the fort's after the
side that lost that was killing the
precursor to our current military the
Confederacy that fought for slavery
doesn't really make a lot of sense
because you've named forts after people
who were against our military they did
not respect our military so listen this
is not the biggest issue I don't really
care what the fort's are called although
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
that we named him after the losers who
wanted to keep slaves but who would have
guessed as Barack Obama was leaving
office that during the subsequent
presidential term NASCAR would take the
more progressive stance of banning the
Confederate flag compared to the
president who defends Confederacy era
statues figures heroes whatever they
like to call him Republican group the
Lincoln project which is a Republican
group that opposes Trump has now come
out and said Trump is the Confederacy's
second prize
this is a Republican group which put out
a statement where they said we never
imagined when we named our initiative to
defeat the re-election of Trump the
Lincoln project that the president would
go as far as honoring the Confederate
generals who fought against the United
States to preserve slavery and uphold
white supremacy for all intents and
purposes Trump today became the
Confederacy's second president we cannot
allow this and then they go on to say we
need help from Republicans to remove
Donald Trump in November strange times
but I believe the decision by NASCAR is
the correct one whatever their reasons
for doing it and it's probably a mix of
understanding the way society is going
combined with the fact that it's
probably a bad PR move to continue
having these flags displayed they did
ultimately come to the right decision